Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie. You probably saw on your feeds
Wonder Woman 3 is basically dead in the water
there have been a bunch of news articles on most
of the big movie sites James Gunn Warner Brothers
the new regime at Warner Brothers had basically
canceled all plans for Wonder Woman 3 as it is
right now so I'll explain what's going on what's
changed because there were a bunch of other big
announcements a bunch of big reveals about the
future of DC movies just in general it wasn't
just about Wonder Woman 3. if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos of course I'll do videos for everything
as they continue to announce things because it's
a developing situation like there was this big
opening Salvo as Wonder Woman 3 was essentially
killed and it's still going on now like it's
still going to continue into next week the week
after but you probably saw gal gadot's post about
the anniversary of her being cast as Wonder Woman
because she was getting hyped up about telling
people about Wonder Woman 3 and it was the version
that she had been working on with Patty Jenkins
for the past couple of years like I can't wait
to show you the next chapter of Wonder Woman and
now that Twitter account poorly aged things are
posting it because like literally the day after
that is when they announced that Wonder Woman
3 had been canceled by Warner Brothers and James
Gunn this is James Gunn's personal response to all
the stuff that was posted about the big shake-up
at DC as for the story yesterday in The Hollywood
Reporter some of it is true some of it is half
true some of it is not true which is actually
probably good news for a lot of you out there that
I got really worried about it I don't know whether
to laugh at this the last little bit here too he
says some of it we haven't decided yet whether
it's true or not meaning that some of the current
slate is undecided like they haven't completely
decided what to do with galakadot's Wonder Woman
Henry Cavill Superman even though it sounds like
they will probably wind up continuing in some
fashion he goes on to say although this first
month at DC has been fruitful building the
next 10 years of story takes time and we're
still just beginning Peter and I chose to helm DC
Studios knowing we were coming into a fractious
environment both in the stories being told and
the audience itself and it would be an unavoidable
transitional period as we moved into telling
a cohesive story across film TV animation and
gaming a big part of James Gunn's plan chance for
the new DC Universe is that everything is going to
be Canon with each other for the most part not
every single thing but most things across the
movies the TV shows even the games for instance
he goes on to say but in the end the drawbacks
of the transitional period were dwarfed by the
creative possibilities and the opportunity to
build upon what has worked in DC so far and help
Rectify what has not meaning that some of the old
stuff will continue like I said we know we're not
going to make every single person happy every step
of the way but we can promise everything we do
is done in the service of story in the service
of DC characters we know you cherish and we have
cherished our whole lives ask for more answers
about the future of the DCU I will sadly have to
ask you to wait we are giving these characters
and stories time and attention they deserve and we
ourselves still have a lot more questions to ask
and answer and in this post here he uses a larger
version of the classic Justice League like even
Green Arrow is in the background like he plans
on doing green arrow in the movies basically so
all the business suits sort of rushed out and
were like whoa whoa whoa before you make any
announcements we have something to tell you
there's going to be a big change in the future
of DC movies and the version of the movie that you
just gave us with this script isn't going to fly
The Hollywood Reporter was the site that actually
broke the news about Wonder Woman 3 being canceled
they said that the project talking about Wonder
Woman 3 as it stood like whatever the treatment
whatever the script the Patty Jenkins gave to them
did not fit with the new but still unfolding plans
for the DC Universe that's like a nice way of
saying that the movie that you gave us isn't
going to fit with our plans so we're not going to
make that movie and as part of the larger shake-up
with the future of DC a lot of people believe now
the James Gunn plans on just basically getting rid
of Snyder verse related stuff recasting a lot
of actors maybe keeping some of the old ones
because some of his own actors like Harley
Quinn for instance Amanda Waller those are
Snyder vs characters but James Gunn doing a soft
retuning of all the characters the backstories
the way that everybody interacts and knows each
other going forward so that it feels completely
different like a completely different vibe for
all the characters we know a little bit about
what Patty Jenkins Wonder Woman 3 was going to be
she'd been talking about it recently I think Patty
Jenkins has even been talking about Wonder Woman 3
for the past couple of years because Wonder Woman
1984 had been delayed for a while so the movie has
been done for a long time but the next movie is
a really good opportunity to course correct on
some of the bigger things most fans had issues
with during Wonder Woman 1984 one of the bigger
stylistic choices that I think a lot of people
were confused by is that if you watch Wonder Woman
1984 it's meant to be as if they made the movie
during the 80s with 80s technology but they're
using modern day technology to pull it off so
the very Spider-Man looking way that she swings
around seems kind of weird or the way she runs
really fast the way they visualize that look kind
of weird but they did that on purpose because they
wanted it to look like it would have looked if
they would have done a Wonder Woman movie during
the 80s but I think a lot of people just felt
like it came off looking a little bit weird and
a little bit silly so I think when they get to
Wonder Woman 3 stylistically they'll try to make
it feel like a more traditional superhero movie
that you would expect to see in modern day but
they did announce that Wonder Woman 3 will be
set in present day probably the biggest change
from the last two movies which are period pieces
setting it in present day also as you guessed
allows them to do it is a crossover movie with
other big Justice League characters which has
become the standard fare in big movie trilogies
at this point the whole thing with a Trilogy is
that you have to escalate with each movie it has
to get bigger and bigger and bigger and sometimes
the only way to escalate things in that final
movie it changed the formula with the last one
is to add a huge crossover character or do it as a
team up movie the big butt now is which character
she'd be crossing over with because a lot of
the other Justice League characters sound like
they're not going to continue we know that Ezra
Miller will not be back they're basically going to
recast him no matter what happens it sounds like
Ben Affleck isn't going to continue under James
Gunn he did film a scene for the Aquaman 2 post
credit scene who knows if that's going to stay in
the movie or if they'll take that out before the
movie's released and even though there's a solid
chance that Henry Cavill could still continue
as Superman now there's a lot of questions
about whether or not that's going to come to pass
because of what was announced about Wonder Woman 3
in James Gunn's plans for sort of shepherding away
the Snyder verse and starting fresh with something
new remember the way he treated his version of
The Suicide Squad movie it was sort of a soft
re-tuning of the characters but sort of kept some
of the things that came before so just because
you're seeing all this news about them moving past
the snyderverse getting rid of that stuff doesn't
mean that they're going to get rid of every single
actor that was cast within that era of DC movies
Gal Gadot was asked a bunch of questions about
crossovers during interviews last week just in
general just in the other DC movies would you
be showing up different places she does have a
cameo scene during Shazam Fury the gods further
complicating matters like if they're canceling
Wonder Woman 3 but she's appearing in one of the
upcoming movies early next year how's that going
to work her Cameo scene is meant to be more in the
tone of the Shazam movies just a little bit more
jokey more comedic Billy Batson has fantasies
about going on a date with Wonder Woman and she
appears during that fantasy sequence like in the
trailer you see a scene where he goes to therapy
and he's talking to PJ Burns pediatrician about
his problems trying to be a superhero and just
live that lifestyle at some point he fantasizes
about her and she appears that way make all the
jokes about Billy Batson being a degenerate in
real life because he's a teenage boy if he had
a fantasy about Wonder Woman it would probably
be pretty raunchy but because the movie's PG-13
they're not going to actually show you what he
would be fantasizing about doing with Wonder
Woman I'll just let you imagine that on your
own everyone letting their degenerate flag fly
the other obvious connection between Wonder Woman
and the Shazam characters is that they shared the
same Pantheon of gods Wonder Woman is literally
a demigod that's part of the Greek gods Pantheon
most of the Gods with the Shazam characters get
their powers from are the Greek pantheon of gods
or from the Greek mythology of gods they'll
get into that more during Shazam Fury of the
Gods as the title implies they'll be fighting
some of the Gods where their powers come from
then there's that whole Patty Jenkins Star Wars
movie that she was working on the Rogue Squadron
movie you may remember they announced it a couple
years ago made a pretty big deal about it at this
big Star Wars present Temptation right after
that announcement was made the regime that was
at Warner Brothers previously who have all since
either left or been fired backed up a dump truck
of money to Patty Jenkins so that she would Fast
Track Wonder Woman 3 and do that instead of doing
Rogue Squadron that's why there's no Star Wars
movie coming out in the next year or two that was
going to be their next big movie they were going
to release and it was going to be their way of
sort of sidestepping the issue of doing Star Wars
episode 10 like we won't do that yet we'll do some
other movie before we do the next big Trilogy
so basically Patty Jenkins has been working on
Wonder Woman 3 for the past couple of years per
the agreement she made with that previous regime
and she shows up to the new regime and they're
like you know what we're gonna pass like I said
though this doesn't mean that she won't do
Wonder Woman 3 it just means that whatever
they were planning on doing for the movie has to
completely change now which means it's going to
take a couple more years for them to fix that like
there will still be Wonder Woman movies obviously
James Gunn plans on using the Justice League he
was literally using Justice League kingdom come
in his post about the plans he was making and
that was his way of telling everyone oh yeah the
Justice League came characters are going to be a
big part of my plans for the next 10 years of DC
movies so the strongest pitches for the story of
Wonder Woman 3 right now are one still do it as
a standalone movie not a huge crossover movie but
you give her a female villain who's also either a
God or at least as powerful as Wonder Woman so
you solve the big complaint of there not being
enough action scenes in Wonder Woman 1984. right
now the best options for another major female
villain would be people like Cersei who's another
God a lot of people have been talking about her
for a long time then you have other characters
like Grail who is basically an evil version of
the Wonder Woman concept number two you take
the team up route and you do Wonder Woman 3
as something like Wonder Woman versus a character
like Black Adam with some of the Shazam characters
like Billy Batson getting cameos because Wonder
Woman shares a lot in common with the Black Adam
character she's ancient just like Black Adam he's
5 000 plus years old so she just has some common
ground that she can speak with him on like look I
get it I do you want your loved ones back but you
need to move on with your life but during Wonder
Woman 1984 she started to replicate some of the
other more complex abilities that Zeus had like
making things invisible without having to spell
cast like she can kind of cast spells a little bit
use magical abilities without having to speak the
words of a spell so visually their fights would be
pretty cool but most people seem to want a female
villain for Wonder Woman 3 then number three
regardless of who they decide the main villain is
going to be or what the story is they should bring
back Linda Carter's hysteria character they hyped
her up so much in that post credit scene she's
supposed to be their greatest Warrior and she's
still out running around the world saving people
while this is all going on so they will wind up
doing Wonder Woman 3 let me know in the comments
what you want that to look like and which other
characters you want to be in that movie I will do
a larger Justice League video about Henry cavill's
Superman coming back and what's happening with the
other Justice League actors because we do actually
know what's happening with some of the Justice
League everyone click here for my Guardians of the
Galaxy 3 trailer video in Easter eggs and click
here for my Deadpool 3 trailer video and Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone one
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!